mm-hmm
i hope you didn't suffer too much that
my favorite aspect of the course was
that you would use the word seven you
give an example of a number so you'd say
a certain field number times a vector
well let's call it seven so seven times
a vector would be so-and-so you know it
can get to extremes right you may end up
doing things like uh
the limit
of uh e to the minus seven uh seven goes
to infinity
uh is equal to whatever it is zero right
anyway yes
what's your field of research
uh not theory
and uh from a very algebraic perspective
and uh related uh algebra things
it used to be
uh
much more not theory and quantum field
theory and it slowly slowly moved to to
being much more algebraic and the
relationship with quantum field theory
became more and more remote
okay what's the relationship let's
forget about the remoteness what's the
close relationship between not theory
and quantum field theory
it's a bit hard to explain
and somewhat surprising and that's why
that's why it took a long time to
discover
let me give you
two answers that are
[Music]
somewhat unrelated and
one answer is that quantum field theory
is about particles
uh
and uh note theory is surprisingly also
about the motion of particles
so
uh you know let's draw a simple-minded
knot
so by the way is this a visible mice
yeah
okay so here is a simple minded knot
it's actually the so-called trefoil knot
but uh
well whatever it is
uh now uh what you can do
is you can
uh so it's living in in r3
and uh i could set up my coordinates
so that
uh
this coordinate will be called t maybe
you want to call it z
but you know i like to call it t
right now and the two coordinates here
are x and y
and then i can slice this knot
at uh equal time
uh slices so basically i uh
draw a plane
which leaves at some fixed height
so at an equal in an equal time plane
and slice the knot and then the slice is
four points
and as i move these points in time
so as i move the slice in time the
points move
and they actually do a little lovely
dance
and
uh the dance is as follows so if we call
these points uh
a
b
c and d
then they start at a certain uh position
a b
c and d
right
and then
as i move
uh
well you can see that c and b trade
places so they play a dance they somehow
dance around each other uh
b goes this way and c goes up sorry b
goes
uh one way and c goes the other way and
after a little while they trade places
so you have
a c
sorry a
uh
c b
d
and as you move the plane even further
they trade places again
so
uh again you will have uh a b
a c d and if you move a little further
again they trade places so you'll have a
c b d
and then something funny happens
uh
uh
points
uh
well points well by this time this is
point b is over here and point c is over
here
and points a is here and d is here and
what happens is that point c moves
towards point d
and points a moves to points point b
and they coincide
and
when they coincide they annihilate each
other because if you look at the plane
which is above
the
the level of the knot
um
uh uh you no longer see any point so
what happens next is that these points
move towards each other as these points
move to each other they meet and bangs
they annihilate and after that there is
an empty set
and in fact i started a tight
uh at a certain height had i started
below i start with the empty set
and instead of annihilation of pairs
you get a creation of pairs so a pair of
points get created here and a pair of
points get created here and then they
perform this nice dance
so this was this particular note but the
same story is true for every note every
note can be written as a certain dance
of points
in which
uh sometimes pairs
get created sometimes pair meet and
annihilate each other and in between
these times they all dance
anyway
uh
physics in general is about the motion
of particles and it's not too surprising
that there is a relationship
physics also sees things like creation
and annihilation of pairs of particles
and i mean so again it's not so
surprising
but this is very very very loose
and
gee the other explanation i can give you
is even more loose
uh
but even but but in some sense
more
closer to the truth
uh well okay maybe you've heard
that quantum mechanics is related to
path integrals
so
uh you know in classical mechanics
uh
you know if a path goes from point a to
point b
sorry if a particle goes from point a to
point b
it goes along a specific path
in quantum mechanics it has a
probability of going uh from a to b and
you compute this probability
by doing a certain
integral
over the space of all paths
so the particle or
i mean again even even my interpretation
of quantum mechanics here is a bit loose
because interpreting quantum mechanics
is a very hard thing
but with this loose interpretation you
uh sum over all probabilities of going
this way or that way or that way
or that way and by adding up all these
probabilities or more precisely
integrating
over the space of all of those
probabilities or more precisely phase
factors or
amplitudes
you
you can compute the probability of going
from a to b
that's quantum mechanics
now
uh
uh likewise quantum field theory but in
quantum field theory it's essentially
the same except the integrals are more
complicated
but the point is that already these
integrals
are not like integrals over rn
right rn
is uh the collection of n tuples of
points a1 up to a n
so a point in rn is determined by n
real numbers
whereas a function the space we are
integrating over now
is the space of all functions and a
function
is determined by infinitely many real
values you need to know the value of the
function here the value of the function
here the value of the function here the
value of the function here so to
determine a function you need to know
infinite infinitely many
uh real numbers
so the integral that you end up doing
is not
157 style sorry now i'm using a
toronto style language or it's not one
variable calculus in integral which is
again one variable
uh integral it's not this
it's not second year calculus when you
do n variable
uh integrals
it's infinite dimensional so infinitely
many variables integration this is what
we need
okay
so
uh
quantum field theory
ended up developing
a bag of techniques for computing
infinite dimensional integrals
and what these techniques are is a whole
different story
but uh
but quantum field theory ended up doing
this
and then
uh
it turns out
that infinite dimensional integrals are
useful to topology
so so the the the
the way that quantum field theory
becomes useful in topology is indirect
it's not that the quantum field theory
itself
is useful
even this is a lie because sometimes the
quantum field theory itself is useful
but the but the main path by which
quantum filter becomes useful to
topology
is not uh
direct but a bit indirect quantum field
theory developed a bag of techniques and
this bag of techniques applies elsewhere
anyway why are infinite dimensional
integrals
useful to topology
um
the answer is again a bit
uh
[Music]
complicated
but let me try to summarize it
so let me bring a knot here's a knot
okay great
uh
uh well actually that's not a knot
why not picking what i'm showing you is
a curve in r3
a note
is
ah
an equivalence class of such curves
this is a curve if i deform it a bit
it's still a curve but it's considered
the same knot if i deform it some more
it's still a curve but it comes but but
but it's the same knot so a knot is not
a single curve but an equivalence class
of curves
now suppose you want
quantities that are associated to knots
you want to be able to tell notes apart
so you need
quantities
uh that would be computable from the
notes and that you would use them to
tell the notes apart
okay
now it's very easy to compute quantities
that are associated with curves
so if you have a curve
uh you can measure its how much it bends
so the radius of of the bending
okay again these things have technical
names the curvature maybe the torsion
there are various
names for for various quantities you can
associate with
curves
so you know i can look at the maximal
curvature of this knot of this curve and
the maximal curvature will be the place
where it turns the most and that's
probably around here for this particular
curve around here okay
now um
but that quantity is a quantity which is
associated with curves
it's a useless as a quantity for notes
it's useless as a quantity for knots
because if we're talking about not you
know i could deform it and the maximal
curvature could go somewhere else
could change could grow could train
could differ
right
so the way to get quantities that are
associated with knots
rather than with
curves
is to integrate over the space of all
geometries
so instead of picking the quantity for a
specific geometric manifestation of the
knot
you integrate over the space of all
geometries and then the result will be a
a quantity associated with the note
unfortunately the examples are very very
hard
so you know the the famous example the
example that uh
got written uh well one of the examples
that got written very very famous in
topology or among mathematicians is the
so-called uh karen simon's theory
uh or turn simon's quantity which is um
uh
so uh in itself some integral so you
integrate over r3
so the quantity itself is a finite
dimensional integral
right so you integrate over r3 something
called the chern simon's form
uh which is something called which is a
wedge d a
plus two thirds
uh
a wedge a wedge a whatever that is but
this is you know related to stuff
appearing in second year uh
multivariable calculus in the most
advanced versions okay so wedge products
and differential forms and exterior
derivatives and stuff like that
then you take this quantity and you
multiply it by i multiply by k
exponentiate it
multiply by another quantity the
so-called holonomi along the note of a
whatever that is so i'm throwing names
because i really have no choice because
giving the precise definition is a
matter for a graduate class yeah okay
and this is the quantity that you
associate with a geometric note
and then to get an invariant of knots or
to get a quantity associated with the
knot itself
you integrate it
over the space of all such a's and i
didn't really tell you what these a's
are but it's an infinite dimensional
space
so
uh i guess i haven't really answered
your question by giving an example but i
just told you the examples are hard
okay anyway um
well they're hard but they're exactly of
the nature
that uh physics knows how to study
or that quantum field theory developed
techniques
to study and so one can study it using
quantum field theory techniques and get
all sorts of um
um
well
quantities relevance to not relevant to
not the so-called john's polynomial is
an example and then there are many other
examples
if you read the bible with letter skips
if you read every tenth letter
you will occasionally find a word
that's not surprising
but the claim was that these words
were
that that it actually happens more than
statistics would
predict and that these words have
messages in them
and
and there was a group of people in
jerusalem
that
published a paper and in fact it passed
peer review
but
so so they published a paper
in which they
supposedly proved this fact
they did careful statistical analysis
again carefully in quotes
uh
and and and and and and showed that the
effect was real
and therefore
the bible uh must have been written by
god
because no human could have put this
information into the bible
it's information information that was
not did not even exist at the time that
the bible was written
and therefore in prayer and so so god
wrote the bible
uh
furthermore it's the hebrew bible
uh so there is a god and that god loves
hebrew more than she loves japanese i
understand yeah uh you know this would
be the greatest discovery in if it was
true it would have been the greatest
discovery in the history of science and
i'm not kidding
right i mean there's no longer an
argument between atheism and tazin
pays and wins
my role was to debunk this
is this real life or not
i don't know i me and a group of people
read critically these assertions that go
that were good enough that they passed
peer review
in a respectable journal
and we found gaps
and the gaps are well we're good enough
that the same peer-reviewed journal
accepted our paper too
okay so you know in some sense my role
was negative right uh what could have
been the greatest discovery in the
history of science and proof that there
is god and it's the hebrew god
uh
was debunked maybe it's a negative
discovery but
well i mean even maybe my effect well my
part was negative i've killed a great
discovery
but that's also a
a valuable thing to do i mean to kill a
the other thing is
otherwise
mathematics plays an extremely limited
role in my life
other than my professional life if you
ex if you cut out
uh the eight hours a day that i work on
mathematics mathematics has no role in
my life or hardly any role so i mean you
do and in fact also almost no role in
your life so basically
you know if you um
you give change in restaurants you uh so
so or in shops sorry you add 15
tip
uh that's about the math you need in
real life
multiplication you don't need
but
but if you're a carpenter you probably
need it
right you need to uh
tile as or you know if you're a trade
person you need to tile a certain room
this the room is five by six right how
many tiles do you need so multiplication
trade people need but but but but people
like me don't need
um trigonometry well maybe architect
nitric architecture trigonometry some
parts of engineering and we get more and
more
esoteric
need higher and higher mathematics
without the very high mathematics
without general relativity
gps satellites wouldn't work so in some
sense we use mathematics every day
but we're not the engineers who designed
gps city live seat satellites gps
satellites were designed by a group of
a very small group of people somewhere
in some
you know
design bureau
and they use high level mathematics so
so so but my real life
high level mathematics
is almost nothing
except once sorry the bible codes and
another time
and i've given talks with this title
so
the title was
the
hardest
mathematics
i've
ever
really
yeah
and if you google this title probably
you'll be able to find a video of that
talk and you'll find the one time
where
it was actually in my professional life
but in a meta way
so not my research but something about
how to present my research i ended up
using uh very high level mathematics
hyperbolic geometry in fact
so one time it happened anyway what was
your next question
why does it take 360 pages of abstruse
symbols to prove that one plus one
equals two occam's razor says we can cut
this we can just say one plus one equals
two because every single last one of us
believes it does
so what do you make of that why is it so
complex to prove something simple like
one plus one equals two do we even need
that
and this question comes from roy dobson
so uh
let me answer the
let me answer
a different question
uh
you know so one plus one equals two so
the reference is probably to uh work of
russell
um
basically
if your axiom system is very very very
basic
and
um
and very very um
primitive in a way very very
simple-minded and you want your axiom
system to be very very very basic
then it might be that even proving one
plus one equal to would be difficult
but it will be a part of the build-up
and later you will be uh
proving harder things and
but the truth is it's silly
okay but let me give you an another
example okay so uh you know there is the
intermediate value theorem
the intermediate value theorem says
uh that if you have a function
continuous function
so if f is continuous
and it's negative here and positive here
then at some point it crosses zero
uh we teach it in week seven
maybe i don't know of undergraduate
calculus maybe it's just week five or
maybe it's week nine i don't remember
okay
you can ask
this is so idiotic
right
why
why does it take five or seven weeks to
prove the obvious that if you go
continuously from here to here you'll be
crossing zero
and the answer
is that when you prove the intermediate
value theorem
you are not actually proving the
intermediate value theorem
you are actually testing
your definition of continuity
you're testing
your abstract setup
you're testing your abstract setup your
your language you're testing
uh
you know the the machinery of for every
epsilon there exists a delta such that
blah blah blah if you could not prove
the intermediate value theorem
you'd be rejecting the abstract system
not the intermediate value theorem you'd
be rejecting this not that
so
the seven weeks were not about the
intermediate value theorem they were
about
this for every epsilon there exists
delta
and then you can ask
what's for every epsilon there exists
delta for why do we need this well we
don't need it to prove the intermediate
value theorem the intermediate value
theorem was testing this
what do we need it for
and the answer is well there are later
things
like
uh e to the x is equal to sum of x to
the n divided by n factorial
which is this by the way looks innocent
and people think they understand it but
it's actually a miracle
and this miracle depends on well it
doesn't depend but i mean there are
maybe other ways to reach there but but
but you you will believe this miracle
miracle after you've understood this
system
so
uh so the answer is uh in a way we
didn't go from uh
uh
here to here
to here
but more like this was known it
validated this and then
we could use it to do other things
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t